[موسيقى]
مسمى السعوديين هل هو مسمى حديث كما يقول
البعض انطلق مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ام مسمى قديم لا هو مسمى قديم الحقيقه
يعني
الشعب نعم الشعب ولهذا نجد في اوائل
الوثائق واوائل المخطوطات لدي بعضها
الحقيقه هو عثرنا عليها يذكرون هؤلاء مثلا
السعوديون او في موقع اقدم شاهد اقدم شاهد
في الدوله السعوديه الاولى وجدنا هذه
الكتابات ايضا المعارك السائره ولهذا بدات
ايضا تخرج هذه الجذور الوحده الوطنيه لا
حول هذا الاسم ينتقلون من مكان الى مكان
فيشيرون الى رمزيه هذا المكان بقياده هذه
الاسره ال سعود
[موسيقى]
مخطوطات قديمه في تحكي بعض الوقائع
التاريخيه ولعلي زودتك
انت زودتني بالفعل بصور لمخطوطه اثنين في
الدوله السعوديه ذكر مسمى السعودي سماه
الطائفه السعوديه طائفه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
تختلف عن الكتابات المؤرخين الاجانب عندما
يذكرون تاريخنا فينسبون ايضا الامر الديني
وهم متاثرين
بينما هذا يقول السعوديه لان هؤلاء
الغربيين
في الحروب كما الاوروبيه القديمه
واللوثريه في تلك الفتره فيحاول اسقاط
ايضا الجانب الديني لكل امر بينما لا
ينظرون ايضا مجتمع وطني قام على اسس ايضا
امنيه في هذه المنطقه
[موسيقى]